stratfor nathan district council is
currently consulting on a site
allocations plan
this video outlines four specific site
proposals put forward in the site
allocations plan in various locations
across stafford navy district
the first one is proposal rural one
former knapton brickworks
the site is located just to the west of
napton on the hill and about two and a
half miles east of southern
it is a brownfield site so the principle
of redevelopment is supported
various planning permissions have been
granted in the past most recently for a
complex of live work units but none have
been implemented
the plan proposes a development of up to
80 dwellings public open space
and a nature reserve development at the
site would remove the current eyesore
and contamination
and control anti-social activities as
well as manage the existing habitats
however it will be important to improve
the relationship between the site and
knapton village
including for pedestrians and cyclists
and take into account the impact of
adjacent adjust industrial uses
an outline planning application for the
site was submitted in november 2018
but it is not yet determined due to the
range of complex issues that need to be
resolved
then we have proposal world 2 university
of warwick wells born campus
this is an extensive site situated to
the north of wells born but with a large
part lying in charcot parish
the site has a long history of research
relating to agriculture
the university is developing a long-term
strategy for the site
a new innovation campus is proposed to
support research and development in a
range of specialist sectors such as life
science
automotive and medical
three specific areas have been
identified for development within the
site
as shown on the map by the hatching
land to the north west of the existing
buildings land to the south
east of the existing buildings and land
fronting salford road for commercialed
stratford road sorry for commercial uses
to help facilitate investment on the
campus itself
the scale and extent of development on
the site will require thorough
assessment due to the range of sensitive
issues involved these include the
proximity of charcot conservation area
and the registered childcare park as
well as the existing trees and hedgerows
then there's proposal rule 3 quintin
rail technology centre near
long marston the plan proposes the
development of a rail-based innovation
and technology facility on this site
it is located several miles to the
southwest of stratford-upon-avon
on part of the former long-marks and
storage depot
it is adjacent to the former
stratford-upon-avon to honeybourne
railway and next to the new community
being established at the unveil
the site provides the uk's only looped
rail test track
and it's only specifically built light
rail test facility
as such the district council considers
it is appropriate to safeguard the rail
related activities on the site
however the council acknowledges that
business needs change over time
and that the site covers a large area as
such it will also support enabling
development that helps secure the
long-term future of rail activities on
the site
the scale and extent of additional
development on the site will need to
take into account matters relating to
flood risk ecology
and trafficked impact
and then finally there's proposal world
war 5 long marston airfield
the core strategy identifies long
marston airfield as a new settlement for
3
500 homes phase one comprising 400 homes
and a local centre
has planning consent and is already
underway
it is acknowledged that there is a major
constraint on the highway network in
stratford-upon-avon particularly south
of the river
however a recent transport assessment
confirms that there is some additional
capacity to enable further development
at the south of the town
before the southwestern relief road is
constructed
the district council considers that most
of this spare capacity should be taken
up by long mars in airfield
since the site is an existing allocation
in the core strategy
the boundary for the long mars in
airfield new settlement is indicated as
a dashed line on the map
the extent of this specific proposal is
shown by a solid line and marked a
it is important to ensure that
development of the new settlement
continues to come forward in accordance
with the approved master plan
and that the necessary infrastructure is
provided alongside new homes
consequently proposal world five seeks
to provide clarity
regarding the next phase of the
development this includes land for
primary school
employment and for open space
i hope you found this useful remember
you can find out more in the site
allocations plan
and submit any comments you have by
visiting our website at
www.stratford.gov
dot uk forward slash zappo